Speaker 1: How about you def from Florida? You
def. Welcome to the program. What's on your mind?
You've muted yourself, which is why I can't
hear you. You have to unmute yourself. You deaf?
Speaker 3: Hey, you hear me?
Speaker 1: Oh, all right. So the
issue wasn't on my end. Yeah. What's going on?
Speaker 3: Hey, David. Good to hear from you.
I had a question about Ron DeSantis
overtaking Trump in the primary polls. Yes.
So my question is, do you think
in a hypothetical Trump loss to
Ron DeSantis that Trump will then
claim voter fraud? And how do you
think his base will react to this claim?
Speaker 1: Oh, you're thinking ahead in a
very logical way, which is imagine Trump fights
for the nomination but loses it to DeSantis.
Trump will absolutely say the RINOs had it in
forum and blah blah blah blah blah, you know,
that type of thing. I believe that at that point
this would be like July of 24 at this point.
I believe at that point the vast majority of the
Republican electorate is not going to go for it.
I don't think they're going to buy. I think it's
just going to be too much. And they'll just say,
now, you know what, the Senate this
is who we voted for. DeSantis is who
we want. It wasn't stolen. And then that's it.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I'm curious about it, because
when he lost in Iowa to Ted Cruz, he also claimed
fraud. And granted, Ted Cruz is not nearly as.
Speaker 4: Popular as de Santos is.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 3: But it seems to not really follow
any kind of logical consistency with the base.
Speaker 1: Correct. Is doing.
Speaker 4: The fraud.
Speaker 1: I agree with you completely. And this
is the thing. At first it was only Democrats who
did the fraud, but then it was Democrats and the
establishment Republican rhinos. And then it's it
it's it inflates and deflates to fill whatever
role it's supposed to fill. And it's the hammer
he has. So everything looks like a nail.
Speaker 3: Got it. Thanks, David.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. Great to hear from
you. Very, very powerful, powerful stuff there.
Okay. I believe I mean, it seems like whatever
technical issues there were were not on my end,
which is good news. So we're
going to continue moving on here.